watch hallmark channel so i was watching
this one and uh
this blew me away drives up
right
she's going to meet this guy
you're hoping they get together
she just left the car on the road she
walks oh he's standing in a parking spot
if you go back to it
she turns down a road that's a regular
road
turns down the road
gets out he's like hey good to see you
and she just goes how are you doing and
then leaves the car in the middle of the
road
and walks to the park and walks through
the parking spot
not even they sit down
they're not even there's no fear there's
no worry of like let me move the car
real fast i don't i feel awkward it's in
the middle of the road people and people
she's just like how you doing she gets
out of the car and yeah the truck is
even poor
you could move the truck out of the
scene and i would probably be okay with
it but the fact that you have a truck
parked now the whole road is blocked